so
foreign
[Music]
here
oh
foreign
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
was
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
i
know
[Music]
[Applause]
i'd like to ask the men to please remove
their caps
may the words of our lips
and the meditations of our hearts be
always acceptable to you o lord our rock
and our redeemer
let us pray
oh god the father creator and preserver
of us all
thank you for the gracious provision of
this day
and all that it represents
may we steward your providential care
faithfully
oh god the son redeemer of our souls
thank you for purchasing us with your
blood
rising for our justification
and ascending for our glorification
may we follow joyfully where you have
led the way
oh god the spirit sanctifier of the
faithful
thank you for filling us with life
uniting us to jesus
and empowering us with your manifold
gifts
may we receive your ministry to us with
love
o glorious and blessed trinity ever one
god
who is the fount of all love laughter
and light
bring us we pray you into your eternal
embrace
may we ever live to praise you
to give you thanks and to glorify you
give us in this life knowledge of your
truth
and in the age to come life everlasting
and all this we ask in the blessed and
most holy name of our savior jesus
christ who lives and reigns with you o
father and you o spirit one god world
without end
amen
please join me in the pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance
please be seated
welcome to this 170th commencement
ceremony of hillsdale college
thank you for coming
let us remember to be grateful for the
blessings of the lord upon this college
which have been abundant
amidst all the trouble in the world
i will tell you that i've been getting
some therapy from our speaker today
i told him i'm having trouble with
schizophrenia
i read the paper in the morning and i
and i get all sour and then i come up
here and i'm happy
and his
advice was more sophisticated this but
more lessened amount to don't read the
paper
this uh ceremony is a wonderful thing
and it takes a little understanding
and i've decided over the years that the
best way to understand it is to
understand why everybody is here
everybody in this room represents
themselves
something important to them
and they represent whole categories of
people
the number in the thousands at least
and mostly in the millions
the ceremony is on the occasion of the
graduation of the seniors
and i'll talk about them in a bit
but
it's not just about them
it took everybody here
and everybody they represent to produce
this ceremony
the form of the ceremony is very old and
continuous
and it's bound to be true if you think
about that that there are reasons for it
take the faculty
what they are is senior
scholars they are the best
and they know more
than
ordinary mortals
and they know more
than these seniors
even now
comparing them to freshmen is hilarious
and the work they have done because
they were all
where you are
in the past
and the work they have done qualified
them
to lead us through
the things we need to know
because of what we are
some of them are retiring i'm sorry to
say
and there's a bunch of them this year
and they're precious
they include barbara bushy
chair and professor of art stand up and
stay standing please while i finish
ken hayes
chair and professor of physics
jim stevens professor of philosophy
one of our very senior most faculty
members
michael sweeney professor of accounting
jim has been here 38 years
sweeney's young 26 years
dan york who couldn't be here today a
professor of biology
please stand up all of you and
thank them for their service
[Applause]
we never we never really announce who's
up here i don't know why we don't but
there's a bunch of pubs up here
including many leaders of the faculty
including chris van orman the provost
from who you heard
and mark called off the dean of faculty
yes
and pat sajak who's the dean of
amusement
what do the faculty do
they uh
live with the students
and i don't mean in any improper way
they uh
they laugh with them
they eat with them they cry with them
there's a lot of blubber babies on our
faculty
always a sign of good character
we reward them for excellence and this
year
i'll name some winners
susan mcnair gave us an anonymous gift
called in
honor of her grandmother for
two a year a junior one time and a
senior the other semester faculty member
and
the role of the ones who won that are
tremendous teachers all of them
and this year
there were two
uh james strasburg
who's
16 years old
and eric hutchinson
who can't be that old because he
graduated from hillsdale college after
i've been here would you two stand up
please
[Applause]
there is a professor of the year
uh it's elected by the senior class
you guys did this
what were you thinking
and it's a big honorific and next uh
one of the two convocations next year
the professor of the year will give a
speech
and this would be a good speech
although i'm not likely to agree with it
all
because
he thinks that petrarch is higher than
aristotle
or he implied that anyway
he's a graduate of the college and he's
just a kid
and i knew him when he was 18 years old
and he's won this thing twice now matt
gaetano
[Applause]
i'd like to ask the faculty to stand so
we can thank them please
[Applause]
thank you
jordan peterson commented to me that
college seems happy
i think it is
and i think that's why we get the best
to come here and teach
thank you
[Applause]
uh the parents are important
they give life
to
you uh in this age we think of
everything is artificial rather than
natural but the word natural
actually means
to be begotten and grow
and so
i think we i think people imagine a
world
where we can do away with the family i
know many people do
and the trouble with that is because
even if the technical means which
probably exists now
to make babies
out of something
these seniors are 21 years old
if they were some other kind of creature
they wouldn't know who their parents are
nor their parents them
and yet this room is full of parents
swelled with pride
they spent a third of their lives or
more
taking care of these
young people
and i can tell you they're very
concerned with the well-being of the of
these young people
much more than i am
they're vital in the literal sense
and what they give to the
children
their children is everything they've got
these parents we have the best parents
here
because we don't take prisoners at
hillsdale college
as you know we stayed open during the
pandemic and
and uh i've had a lot of questions
what did the mothers say about that
and i said well i did answer a question
at parents weekend one time they said a
woman asked me a mother asked me
what will you do if they die
and i replied we can get more
and the mother's always
you know
there's a parents organization steering
committee and they're very active
and they
uh they raise they come they come here
and they descend on the campus like a
plague in the week before parents
weekend
and they call people on the phone and
they make them give us a lot of money
they shame them it's extremely effective
and and
and
they drink wine
while they do it which makes them more
effective
and they and so we got these old people
and they're turning the place into a
party school
it's gotten out of hand and and now this
year
they uh
made up a bunch of buttons anybody got
your button on today
yeah see if you look for the buttons and
what it says is
i'm not re you know their kids
graduating now right so
i'm not ready to be finished with
hillsdale college
in other words they don't care if their
kids here or not
and so we have started
and they're going to be in it they're
going to be the founding members of it
we've started the alumni parents
organization
and you'll all be invited to come back
in parents weekend
and we're going to get extra security
will the parents stand up please
[Applause]
general malloy is the outgoing chairman
with his wife and they've had
400 children here
where's he stand up general
yeah yeah
he's an air force general and that means
he was prepared to serve and fight for
his country and maybe die but he wanted
to sleep in a warm bed every night
the retiring members of the steering
committee i'd like them to stand up and
be recognized because they're the ones
who did the most work and made the most
trouble too would you all stand up
please
they're friends of the college here
they don't have a family connection
they're about a thousand of them here
there are about 25 million of them
elsewhere
they support the college
they take its online courses
they don't get anything back
i mean
they like to watch
these guys
on a small and you know they're
beautiful people but they're not fashion
models
and they and they like to watch them on
a small screen talk about complicated
stuff
and they flock to college events
and they contribute to the college very
large sums
no college without them
no college without the parents no
college without the faculty
they're all involved take any one of
them out
and this is not happening today
ever
you see
and that means that everybody in this
room
and everybody watching
is part of the achievement that we're
here to celebrate today
and i want to thank you all
[Applause]
[Applause]
as i say it's not only about the seniors
although they're very full of themselves
i can tell you
but they are the occasion
where we
celebrate
the eternal work of the college which
goes on all the time it must go on in
your lives
from here because you're not done yet
but there'll be more after you and after
that and after that
and so this is a way to mark
an eternal thing with time and you are
passing
a big milestone
you have done it
you have left your mark for example
no senior class
has ever stolen as many bottles of wine
out of my house after senior dinner
i was a little cranky about it and then
one of them had heard the story which
i'm afraid it's true
that i once had to caution the faculty
against walking down the street with
bottles of wine after an outdoor dinner
and they just thought well they can do
it we're seniors now we can do it but
they did bring them back and they were
in good grace
they made a lot of messes
they always do this was pretty bad i
think though
simpson and galloway big boys dorms
they're the two worst
which was worse this year
the simpson guys will say simpson and
the galloway guys say galloway
but enough of that
there have been some real achievements
among these students
an unusual thing a unique thing in my
experience
the top ten
has four boys in it
have you have you ever heard of such a
thing
now i'll tell you something weird this
college has
slightly more boys than girls
and they're drawn from a pool the same
size and the same qualifications you
can't distinguish them
and so they ought to do exactly the same
and they don't
and i for years i've laughed about it
and figured out about it and then two
years ago
this young man here who's implicated in
this event that i'm going to describe to
you because i can't shut up about it
there was an episode of
deer urine
being thrown on galloway hall
by people from
simpson hall
and
i heard about it my son-in-law told me
about it he was very concerned oh
they're throwing deer urine and i said
i'll be darned
he said
he said what are you going to do about
that and i said i don't know i'll find
out so i go to the staff meeting and i
asked dean phillip
what about the deer urine and she said
well i heard something about that i
don't know what it was and i said well
i've got those boys in class
and so i'll ask them
so i walked in the class and i said
first words
what's this about deer urine
and
reagan dugan who works here now
and his parents the dad works here and
they're in this audience somewhere
he said
dr arn
that was a perfectly honorable act
and i replied okay
and
we have an outstanding senior man and
woman
a very great honor
and this year's outstanding senior man
about to go into the
marine corps
is implicated in that crime
grand boys stand up
[Applause]
now everybody here
loves grand boys because he's
ridiculous
everybody here loves the outstanding
senior woman
because she's got to be the nicest
person on earth everybody thinks that
right
and her name is rachel kitty please
stand up
[Applause]
she is really sweet
she try to meet her
don't worry about grant
the salutatorian is
rebecca felton where she stand up please
[Applause]
she has
we don't like four points here right
because that's
bad
and
she has a 3.9999
something
right
we have
co-valedictorians
and in a miracle
one of them is a boy
the co-valedictorians are rose koster
and cliff yang stand up
[Applause]
rebecca majors in biology and rose and
cliff i'm sorry majors in history
and rose and cliff
major in biology and chemistry
and i think that proves doesn't it
professor koltov that history is more
difficult than biology chemistry
i've been told a hundred times not to do
this and so i'm going to do it
the president's ball king and queen
are aiden cyrus and natalie kent please
stand up
come on
stand up you're not done yet
[Applause]
natalie kent
in the flesh
was miss teen usa
[Applause]
grant boys was never going to win that
distinction
the senior class officers
have been a really great bunch and this
was uh
it was lucky in part we got a great
commencement speaker don't you think
and there was unity and the way the way
that's done is
the officers go poll the students and
ask them who they want and
they all understand we're not going to
invite any ax murderers here
and you know sometimes they want
well i'm not going to say what kind of
people they want
often it's really great but sometimes
it's just celebrities
this time
and we make a list in the administration
and
i have the power to decide
i like power
and i try to keep something crazy from
happening but the faculty will attest i
have not always succeeded in that
and so this year it was just the most
harmonious thing in the world
and we got the person who was top of the
list
and the ones who did that made that list
and reasoned with me about it are jacob
hooper the president please stand as i
call your name
and
somebody
what is her name
she's marrying that flasher boy and he's
not worthy of her
penny heibel is the secretary she works
in my office
[Music]
stephanie walker is the treasurer
and chloe kersey is the social chair
thank you for your service very much
it was a great year
as a group and individually
these seniors are the best
we ever had
and i went back in my notes from last
year and verified that i said that last
year too
and it was true both years
and i expect it will be true next year
you get a year to be top of the heap
but you are awesome people and you will
be greatly missed here
except you're not leaving after all are
you
you're going to live the life
that you have prepared yourself to live
and you're going to live it in contact
with this college which is a partnership
that includes you
till death us do part and beyond
[Applause]
uh jordan peterson is a clinical
psychologist he's the chancellor of
ralston college in savannah georgia just
been announced at that it's interesting
i uh
it's a rare thing when i see some new
education venture that i think holds
promise and that one seems to me to do
so
and you would think that in part because
he's in it
he's a uh
prolific man
he knows the data
in psychology studies
he quotes
young and freud with authority
i had never thought that was a virtue
but but i'm learning that it can be
his discipline doesn't explain him
though
because he's interested in everything
and i've been talking to him much of the
day today which i insisted on doing
because
perks of power
and
he knows a lot
and he's quick
and his diagnosis of what's gone going
on in the world
is marvelous
it's like mine
and
and better
some important ways
he uh
started rebelling
against the wokeness that's
like a plague settling on education and
the land
and if it settles there on education
the land will die and he has stood up to
that
he uh
he wrote a complicated book
about psychology
and then he wrote a simpler book that is
however
complicated and it became an
international phenomenon
and his youtubes and his
speeches and everything he does
millions of people attend to them
and i started attending to them first
our children started attending to them
then i hear you students mention them
and some of the faculty
and i thought this is a
phenomenon
this is a happy thing
in a difficult age
he has proved to be also and finally
brave
he was
rather than submit
himself to the questionnaires
and the
testament testimonies that one must give
about your commitment to
diversity
and if you think about that what does
that mean by the way it just means you
prefer the different to the same
i don't in principle why would that be
and he couldn't put up with it anymore
and he gave up his tenure at a great
university or formerly great university
toronto
and he's become
a teacher of millions
i'm pleased to welcome jordan peterson
[Applause]
so you seniors
you graduates
you're at a pinnacle
of sorts
um
with any luck it won't be the last one
that's one metaphor pinnacle another how
about a crossroads
you're at a crossroads right you're
entering a new phase of your life you
can
you're someone different than you were
four years ago
and hopefully someone better
likely someone better
and you have another opportunity now to
be
the next iteration of yourself
that you can be
at a crossroads you know
the metaphor works because you make a
decision you go one direction or another
and there's an old blues
idea that you
meet the devil at the crossroads
i always wondered why that was i thought
it through it's a really compelling
idea you know it's a it's an image that
has a good narrative fit and it sticks
in your memory once you hear it why do
you meet the devil at the crossroads at
midnight maybe that's when you
examine your conscience
or it examines you
and then you might ask well why do you
meet the devil at the crossroads
and answer is most fundamentally because
when you come to a place in your life
where you have to make a choice
and i think this is actually true of
every choice we ever make but it's more
evident when the choice is more
weighty let's say
now's the choices that lay themselves
out now in front of you are weighty
you aim up or down
and there is always an agent of
temptation at every choice point
enticing you
to aim down
and i thought a lot about what aiming
down means and so i'll
run through that for a bit
the spirit of temptation manifests
itself for example in the story of cain
and abel and so cain falls prey to
temptation and god
bluntly
informs him
when he complains about his fate that
the temptation was freely chosen and
that he could have
done differently and better
and
cain becomes
this is in the aftermath of the improper
sacrifices that he makes
the sacrifices that he makes that are
not
everything they could be
they're not in the service of the
highest good
that are deceptive
and arrogant simultaneously because
when we make improper sacrifices we
believe in the deepest part of ourselves
that we've pulled one over god
and isis suggests that that's a
temptation you might want to avoid that
presumption
and then you might say well
if you're tempted to
aim down
you're tempted to make improper
sacrifices you're tempted to arrogantly
presume that you are going to get away
from it with it
that you're not going to be called on it
what are the pathways down that might
manifest themselves in front of you and
i think the the two stories that follow
the story of cain and abel
detail that
so after cain and abel comes the flood
and that's no accident the narrative
placement of those stories is definitely
no accidents it's unbelievably
sophisticated from a literary
perspective philosophical perspective
theological perspective
existential perspective one form of
temptation is
the nihilistic
chaos that's
symbolically represented by the flood
right it's
the proliferation of sins
and sin is a word
both its greek and its hebrew derivation
are related to archery
so the greek derivation i hope i haven't
got this wrong because i know there are
greek scholars in this audience so um
the the the word is derived from the
greek word hamartia which means to miss
the mark and it's an archery term it's
it's lovely i it's a lovely notion to
know that because to sin therefore means
to miss the target which implies that it
has something to do with aim or the lack
thereof
i love that i think it's so apt and the
derivation of the word sin from the
hebrew source actually relies on the
same imagery and so to sin is to aim
wrong or to miss the mark there's a
variety of ways you can miss the mark
right don't aim at all that's a good one
assume there is no such thing as aim
assume all aims are equal
well you sin you miss the mark
what can happen well one way is you can
descent into a kind of nihilistic
hopelessness and that's not
you can understand that you know you
meet people in life whose lives have
been so hard you hear their stories
they've suffered so much and they're
bitter and they're hurt and they're
resentful and you think oh my god it's
wonder you're bitter and resentful i
mean look what you've gone through
and but you also notice that their
bitterness and their resentment and
their hopelessness and their chaos and
their anxiety it's not helping
right it's worsening the problem it's
not making it better and i'm not saying
that people can always resist that
but i i i have certainly seen that it's
not helpful but i've also met other
people you know who have had stories
equally catastrophic sometimes more
catastrophic sometimes so catastrophic
you can't even believe that they
survived who are not embittered or made
resentful by those experiences and who
continue to aim up and so that makes a
mockery of the of the of a kind of
casual determinism right is that you end
up chaotic nihilistic hopeless anxious
etc
merely as a consequence of the
unbearable tragedy of your life because
if that was the case then everyone who
had a series of unbearable tragedies
which by the way will be almost all of
us in one way or another at one time or
another would end up
in that
catastrophic chaos that that once
that if manifested broadly enough in a
society produces a flood of
that ends everything and that's well
that's the story of noah in large part
and noah you know he's wise in his
generations was a lovely phrase because
it means for his time and place he was a
good man and that's that's a lens
through which history might well be
viewed you know we're very presumptuous
as moderns we look back and we think
well you know this person who did all
these remarkable things said these
things that we now regard as
inappropriate and therefore can be
dispensed with it's like well
what makes you think that you're above
that criticism 100 years from now that
you know the best you can do is to be as
good as you can in your time and place
and if you can manage that well good for
you if you can transcend that well then
maybe you're some sort of saint and
you're probably not so amen at just the
first is not such a bad upper aim and so
there's the chaos domain and i would say
those of you who are graduating you want
to be tempted into that you know one of
the things i've thought a lot about in
relationship to faith you know we have
this idea it's not a good idea and it's
certainly a idea for which religious
people are often pilloried that faith
means the sacrifice of reason and the
willingness to believe things that are
patently not true and when religious
people debate scientists they're often
sort of hung out to dry on exactly those
presump presuppositions their
willingness to accept on principle
propositions that seem on the face of
them impossible
i don't think that's what faith is at
all in in some fundamental sense
i think faith is a form of courage
you know if you're hurt by life and you
will be
it's understandable that you might react
in a nihilistic and hopeless fashion and
become anxious and depressed and cynical
and bitter in all of that
that's a bad pathway
and i think part of what helps you
through that is faith and and part of
that faith is that it's incumbent upon
you and actually in your best interest
and everyone else's
to maintain faith in the fundamental
goodness of existence including your own
despite the evidence to the contrary
right because you can draw conclusions
from suffering in two ways right one is
that you have a duty and perhaps the
capability to transcend the suffering
and still serve the good or you can
derive the conclusion that life is so
unbearable that it would be best
terminated which is the conclusion that
girth as mephistopheles derives for
example in faust he says well
the world is rife with suffering and
it's so unbearable that consciousness
itself all being should cease to exist
that would be better nothing is better
than something if something is rife with
suffering and you can derive that
conclusion and you'll be driven to it in
some
of the farther reaches of your life when
terrible things happen to you but i
would say
faith is the courage to not take that
path despite the evidence that that
might be justified
and so i think it is a form of courage
in the highest sense and i also think it
is a redeeming form of courage one of
the things i told my daughter who is
very very ill for a very long period of
time in tremendous pain and suffering
the high probability of continued slow
painful inevitable degeneration was
do not
let your illness do not take advantage
of your illness as an excuse and i told
her that when she was in grade two you
know it's no joke to tell someone that
because i knew she'd had every reason to
be embittered but i also knew that if
she was
in combination with her illness the two
things might be worse than fatal and you
know if you don't think there are things
that are worse than fatal you have not
suffered because there are things that
are much worse than fatal and that's
certainly not something you want to doom
your child to
so that's the
that's one temptation right that's the
temptation of
kind of faithless hopelessness
and then an all me you might say
existential angst that you allow to
pervade yourself and i'm not saying you
won't have your reasons
because you will i'm saying that the
reasons don't justify the conclusion and
they certainly don't justify the
conclusion not self-evidently and they
don't justify the conclusion in any
simple deterministic sense you know i
met
met a woman once in my clinical practice
man this was
something she was as damaged a person as
you could hope to contemplate
so she looked like a street person she
come to this behavior therapy clinic
that i worked in as a student and
she was dressed like a street person you
know she had this old ratty
winter jacket on that was really dirty
and and she stooped over she wasn't very
tall to begin with she stooped over
hunched over and she approached everyone
like like this
which made people shy away from her
because it's an odd method of approach
but the reason she did that was she was
really so timid and so humble that it
was if as if anybody that she approached
had a light that was emanating them to
from them too unbearable for her to
behold so it wasn't so much an oddity
although it was as an uh
well pretty natural humility and
i thought she had come to the behavior
clinic because she wanted help she was
an outpatient at a psychiatric hospital
that i worked at
and
she couldn't communicate very well
partly from because of her shyness
partly because her first language was
french would maybe she could communicate
perfectly well in french but i doubt it
um she was not an intelligent person
technically speaking you know she she
was intellectually impaired and probably
in the bottom 10th percentile the
population that's a pretty rough place
to exist cognitively you know you're
barely literate at that point and
and her mother was a
was very ill and was uh
bedridden and
her her mother had a boyfriend who was a
violent alcoholic schizophrenic who was
always haranguing her about satan and
like man she had a rough life it was she
just didn't have anything going for she
wasn't an attractive person physically
you know people shied away from her
she just was the downtrodden of the
earth you know in the realist sense and
that bloody woman you know she actually
came to that
behavior therapy clinic
she'd been an inpatient
and this was a rough place man because
it was a hospital after
de-institutionalization and there were
tunnels connecting some of the wards to
other wards because it's so cold this
was in montreal it's so cold in the
winter they built a hospital on these
tunnels and i took my brother there one
day and it was like walking through
dante's inferno i mean if you were so
psychiatrically impaired that you
weren't released in the 1980s when the
institutionalization was maybe at its
peak you were so damaged that there was
just no possibility that you could
function in the outside world so the
people that were left were sort of the
the most
demolished of the most demolished and so
just walking through there for my
brother who had no experience in such
things was traumatizing you know and and
she had been in the inpatient ward
for some time and then was released and
she
wanted to talk to the hospital
administration because she got out she
got this dog that she took care of and
went for a walk and she really liked
this dog and she took care of it you
know and she walked with it and she
wanted to see if she go find one of
those on inpatients who was worse off
than her
and take them for a walk every day with
her dog
you know
it's so funny you meet someone like that
and they just have nothing they have
nothing in the world that you would
recognize as any marker of success
or or status or ability or
they're outcast and tortured and and
then none of that nonetheless you know a
woman in that dismal state was able to
rise above her own catastrophe which was
like manifold and find someone worse off
to try to serve
you know
you don't need many experiences like
that to convince you that there's things
about the world that you truly don't
understand on the ethical front you know
so i would say when you're at the
crossroads and you're counseled to
despair
you know rise up and courage and see if
you can resist it
it's better for you and it's better for
the people around you
so
that's the flood man and so
the story that falls out of the tower of
babel
you know i was reading a wikipedia
article on the tower of babel the other
day uh
i'm always curious about how these
things are represented most publicly
right and wikipedia is a great way to do
that because it's collectively edited
and the interpretation was essentially
it was the description of how the
languages of the world arose
and i think i don't think that's what
that story is about at all except
peripherally i thought yeah you just
missed the point 100
i mean babel is babylon first so you
need to know that and babylon is the
state that's gone mad
and it's an it's a continual temptation
for human beings to build
complex organizations right
that get too high and so what does that
mean how about too many layers not local
enough not distributed enough right two
separate from the people that they serve
i think the eu did that i think that's
why the british left that's a tower of
babel in fact they used unbelievably
they used a famous painting of the tower
of babel as a representation of the eu
in some of their
literature which i think it was a
painting by brugel but i'm not sure of
that but that was just like okay i don't
i just do not understand how that
happened at all
in any case
this tower of babel it's it's also a
luciferian story you know lucifer is the
spirit of intellect the lightbringer who
who's flown too high and
challenges god himself
and falls and in milton's story lucifer
is called on his pretension by god and
said you know if you because he is god's
highest angel god most catastrophically
wrong so a symbol of intellect that in
combination with the notion that he's a
lightbringer it's a symbol of prideful
intellect and it is the prideful
intellect that raises itself against
what is most properly placed at the
highest place which is what god is
whatever that is
whatever it is it's not the intellect
that's a subordinate spirit and if it
isn't then it becomes aimed essentially
at something approximating hell and
perfectly capable of creating it and
then perfectly capable of ruling in it
and so god when god calls lucifer on his
rebellion he says if you but repent you
could be welcomed home and lucifer says
well i am the sort of spirit that even
if i once repented i would be instantly
tempted to merely repeat my my mistake
and he says as well i would rather rule
and held and serve in heaven it's like
hey man
there's a choice for you at the
crossroads
and so you know people have asked me for
example i'm very opposed to the idea
that the fundamental human motivation is
power which is pretty much what every
student is taught at every level of
their education in every educational
institution except a handful now across
your country fundamental motivation is
power there's no place for people of
good will to meet and have and engage in
constructive dialogue dialogues none of
that because our fundamental motivation
is nothing but the will to power and so
there is no place for people of good
will to meet there is no such thing as
dialogue it's all a mask a
rationalization a post-hoc
rationalization for
pretension and power it's such a dismal
philosophy it's so you could not and i i
believe this technically you could not
formulate a more pathological philosophy
it obliterates your faith in society and
it eradicates the notion of the
individual it removes the notion of good
faith and good will and it makes
communication impossible it's like
that's a temptation to engage in that
sort of destruction as a consequence of
your intellectual protections let's say
and for all of you this is going to face
you too this pretension you know so
maybe you're not the hopeless type and
and and the temptation that assails you
at the crossroads isn't your
degeneration into a kind of faithless
nihilism maybe it's a
self-aggrandizement in some sense
instead and that you feel that now you
have the opportunity to serve your own
ambition
well we can take apart what that means
because i think it's worthwhile
psychopaths serve their own ambition
and they're the people who are most
truly motivated by power by the way if
you think about it clinically and
they're not very successful all uh
protestations to the contrary they never
rise above about three percent of any
general population
and maybe it's a better strategy to be a
psycho manipulative psychopath than to
lay inert on your in your bed in your
mother's bedroom when you're 40 but it's
not an optimal strategy
and so you can be get away with it being
a psychopath because you can mimic
competence and you can take advantage of
people who have learned to expect the
best from others and so you can
manipulate them but you produce nothing
on your own and one of the things that's
really interesting about psychopaths is
they don't learn from experience which
means not only do they betray other
people constantly
but they betray their own future selves
and there's really no difference between
your future self and someone else right
you know if you're going to act
ethically and this is a very good way of
thinking about acting ethically you act
in a way that works for you now
that works for you tomorrow that works
for you next week and next month the
next year and in five years and in ten
years and for you and your family and
your friends and your broader community
and all of that simultaneously
and that's that's a place to find
purpose in your life to manage that
balancing act simultaneously and to
sacrifice your narrow
self-oriented pretensions ambition all
of that the celebration of your own
intellect the the construction of your
own empire for your own narrow purposes
part of the reason you shouldn't do that
even though it's tempting in some sense
especially if you have the ability is
because do you want to rule over hell
i mean and that's another interesting
question with regards to the question of
whether power is a valid motivation it's
like
okay well kim jong-un let's take him
he's a manifestation of a power player
you are you think it's better to be
leader of north korea than to be just an
ordinary peon there are you so sure it's
better to rule over hell than just to be
a servant in hell it's not obvious to me
that's not success by any stretch of the
imagination the most powerful devil
that's like the worst possible failure
and so you know you're called upon to
to take the lessons that you've been
taught in a university like this that
the teachers attempts to teach you to
abide by the eternal verities to
sacrifice your own narrow pretensions in
the highest sense to something that's
truly better not because you should in
some figure finger wagging sense but
because there is truly nothing better
and perhaps you don't have the wisdom to
see that because it's difficult to see
it's difficult to have a purview broad
enough to encompass those expanse of
time and community and see what pattern
of behavior is to be manifested in
proper service to balance all of that in
some musical manner
but that's definitely the
that's definitely the appropriate
pathway it's the best possible path of
action and anything you pursue that
isn't that is insufficient especially
for people of your ability and i would
also say and this is very much worth
thinking about too you know there is
this idea that your great country is
founded upon for example that
each individuals of divine worth
you know i made reference to this client
i had when i was a junior therapist and
so even the the most what would you say
ignored and and and alienated
marginalized let's say to use a word
that's been overused have something of
real value to bring into the world and
this is the case you're a particularized
creature as a son of god or a daughter
of god let's say you have something to
bring into the world that no one can
else no one else can bring in
and so if you fail in that duty then you
deprive the world of that
and maybe you shouldn't do that like
maybe everything's lesser if you do that
and you don't know how much lesser you
know because the world is also
constituted in a very strange way you
know dostoevsky said that we're not only
responsible for what we do but for what
everyone else does which is truly an
insane thing to say but also in some
sense fundamentally true you know i
don't know how it is that each of us can
bear the burden of the world on our
shoulders singularly because
i can't really comprehend how things can
be structured in that manner but i do
believe nonetheless that it is the case
and so that if you forswear your
responsibility to the highest good then
you tear something out of the fabric of
being that
that is of inestimable value and i do
believe you will pay for that if you do
it and i would suggest that you don't
pay that price because it will not be
pleasant that's definitely hell
and if you don't think hell is real you
haven't thought about it enough
it isn't a matter of other people
believing foolish things it's a matter
of you being so naive and so well
protected that you have no idea how the
world is constituted
and so
and so that's well that's the
temptations let's say
chaos and nihilism and hopelessness or
intellectual pretension and the desire
for self-aggrandizement and narrow power
don't do that it's not helpful it won't
do you any good and it it's beneath you
you know it's beneath you to do that
and you and you that will manifest
itself in your life that that that that
subordination of what's highest in you
to those lesser gods let's say
battles manifest itself in the torments
of your own conscience and no one
escapes from that you know and so
don't do that
don't make that choice at the crossroads
and then we might say practically
speaking because i'm a behavioral
psychologist you know i like to be
practical well that's what you shouldn't
do
what should you do practically well
we could walk through that you know a
little bit
practically
i'll have lots of
clients and students who were chaotic in
their orientation life they didn't know
what to do and they didn't know what to
do about not knowing what to do it's
like i don't know what to do with my
life and i don't know what to do about
my ignorance and my act my reaction to
that in some sense wasn't exactly the
reaction of a clinician because
not a typical clinician because typical
clinicians are liberal protestant in
their fundamental orientation and they
tend to think of psychological
development as something like
self-actualization right it's really a
self-development
process but i i that wasn't my my
observation partly
influenced by the developmental
psychologist sean piaget i had a more
communitarian view of human development
than that and my observation was that
most people find the sa the cardinal
meanings in their life not
as a consequence of the development of
their self whatever that is but in
service to other people in in the
adoption of responsibility you know
because you're told be responsible and
it's a finger wagging thing again you
know that if you were a good person
you'd be responsible you do your duty
but no one ever says
well because that's where you find the
abiding meaning in your life and you
need that meaning to sustain you through
suffering and that's definitely the case
you know i was very ill for a number of
years and a lot of what got me through
that wasn't my own special
nature let's say but the support of my
family and the support of my friends and
the support of the broader community
made a huge difference not only
psychologically because i knew people
were supporting me but also practically
you build yourself a community
you sacrifice yourself in the service of
other people not so much because you
should although you should but because
that is where meaning is to be found and
you need a deep meaning to sustain you
through tragedy that's the arc
and you find that deep meaning and you
know there's a notion that it's better
to give to receive than to receive and
it sounds like a hallmark greeting card
in some sense and and people are cynical
about that too yeah you say that because
you should be good and think that and
but if you watch yourself you'll see
that it's true because one of the things
that's been really
uh pronounced element in my life is that
you know people thank me from time to
time from for things that i've done or
said and there isn't a better
experience than that you know that you
put something out that's actually a
manifestation of what you truly believe
and the consequence of that is
part of the redemptive process for
someone else there is nothing that's
better than that zero nothing in fact i
don't think there's anything that's even
in the same
conceptual universe of that in terms of
its intrinsically rewarding properties
there's nothing better than to have
people as perhaps particularly people
you've never met tell you that what you
have been doing has had a salutary
effect on their lives
that's and so that's a hell of a fine
thing to aim for and why not import you
know because you could do it
if you put i don't i wouldn't even say
necessarily that you put other people
first because i think that's a mistake
but i do think it's the case that you
treat other people
at in the manner that you would wish to
be treated if you were treating yourself
properly and that's also a sophisticated
thing right to learn to treat yourself
properly because that doesn't mean you
get to fulfill every momentary whim
because that's what you do when you're
two and two-year-olds can't live without
their parents
you know you have to be wise enough to
govern your current behavior in light of
the future and that's really what it
means to be an adult it's what it means
to forestall gratification
and to and to attain the responsibility
of an adult and the reason that you
should do that because you should is
because it's actually better you know in
all ways it's it's an it's a panacea for
suffering to adopt that responsibility
and so i would tell my clients and
students as well it's like well let's
just take a look at where other people
find meaning
you know and and we'll see how your life
matches with that do you have an
intimate relationship
yes or no the right answer is yes now
maybe not for you and maybe you don't
right now and maybe you have your
reasons not to because you're a singular
person in that regard but probably not
because that's like a third of life and
so if you don't have that
that might be one of the reasons you're
not doing so well and the fact that you
don't have it might be an indication
that you're not oriented in the proper
direction oh i can give you an example
that i had many people questioned me
when i was just on tour
this is a question that came up quite
rapidly often
in the q and a sessions
how do i find the right person when i'm
dating how do i find the person who's
right for me when i'm dating i got that
or on the internet
i got the question like three times in a
row and i thought because i always think
this what about that question
what's wrong with that question
something wrong with that question
how about
how do i conduct myself so that i am the
best possible partner
now that's a whole different right
that's a whole different conceptual
universe and virtually no one ever asked
that question and i would say well if
you want an answer to the first question
which is how do i find the person who's
right for me you actually start by
asking the second question which is what
can i bring to the table for someone
else and if you're really good at
bringing something to the table for
someone else hey man people might be
lining up to be your partner and if
they're not then you might think well
maybe i'm just not bringing the right
thing to the table
and that's worth thinking especially if
you're desperate you're lost and you're
alone it's like hmm
maybe i got this wrong and i you know i
usually sort of top that with the
suggestion that even if you did find the
person who was perfect for you and
they're that perfect what makes you
think they wouldn't take one look at you
and run screaming away and they likely
would if they were that perfect because
you know really are you that much of a
catch
and if you think you are you know that
might be part of the problem
um
so so look so that's one right intimate
relationship so i would say to you at
the crossroads
develop a vision for your relationship
you know there's a gospel saying which
is of course impossible to comprehend or
believe knock on the door will open
asking you will receive seek and you
will find and people think well no way
the world's not constituted like that
it's like it goes back to the idea of
aim
if you don't aim at it you're not going
to hit it
and you know it might also go back to a
question about what do you mean by ask
and what do you mean by want because it
isn't just some casual request you know
you're praying to god i wish you know i
wish i could find my wallet or something
like that as if he's the casual grantor
of magical wishes like like like a fairy
with a magic wand you know it's not that
asking means asking means something like
this i am willing to give up everything
that i'm doing wrong
so that i can put things right if i
could know what right was
and that's a non you're on your knees
when you say that man and maybe if
you're on your knees you get the answer
and so that's worth thinking about so
you know if you knocked and you wanted
to walk through and you asked and you
wanted to learn
you know and you sought because you
wanted to find maybe you would
receive
and
be answered and
find
but not without aim and so i might say
well look if you could have the
relationship you wanted
you get to have the relationship you
want and need
but you have to know what it is
and so then you need a vision of that
it's like an and a developed vision you
know no i need to find the person right
for me it's like what do you mean by
that
no
how about how are you going to treat
your partner when they come home from
work how about something that concrete
or how would you like to be treated when
you come home from work
or what sort of partner do you want in
relationship to their attitude towards
children you have to make it real you
know like it's the story of your own
life which by the way it is and then
maybe you find it because at least once
you've developed the vision if it
manifests itself you'll recognize it
that's something
so then you need an intimate
relationship well
why don't you set your family right
no you need siblings maybe you don't
have them set your relationship with
your parents right fix your relationship
with your father with your mother with
your siblings
the same thing and then what sort of
relationship you have with want to have
with your children
you know if you could have what you
wanted i had a very good relationship
with my children
my daughter as i said was very ill so
that made things complicated but i had
great relationship and still do with my
son it's it's one of the lights of our
life
and we concentrated on making that
relationship pristine you know both of
us and my wife as well
and so
imagine well i want my son to love me i
want my son to respect me and vice versa
i want a child who can make mature
decisions i want someone i can rely on i
want someone who other people gravitate
towards
because i can have what i want if i'm
willing to make the proper sacrifices
and so that's that's a good thing could
you set your family straight
well you need a job or a career
and so what can you offer and what can
you bring in the world in that regard
and not and then i would say well if
you're thinking about career success in
this tower of babel manor then that's a
temptation but you might think well how
much could good could i do if i had the
opportunity in the shortest possible
period of time if i went all in
and then that's there's a name man
there's a name and then you might think
well what would that look like you know
if i was a light to my community if i
was a light to the people i work with
who would i be if i was like that
and and then you can conceptualize that
and you can see when you deviate from it
and why couldn't you
correct for the deviations and move
towards that
and then you might say well you are
going to make productive use of your
time outside of work productive and
generous use of your time productive
generous and meaningful use of your time
how about that
you're going to control your
your susceptibility to temptation
regulate your alcohol and drug use
because alcoholism takes out lots of
people regulate your sexual temptation
can control yourself for some reason
that's worth controlling yourself for
you know because there's something to
being subordinated there's at least the
momentary pleasure it's not nothing and
you're not going to sacrifice that if
you have any sense unless you sacrifice
it to something clearly better you know
most this is classic clinical finding
with regards to alcoholics the only
cure we know for alcoholism is religious
transformation
even the hardcore secular researchers
know that they don't know why but they
know that's the case and part of the
reason for that is that if you're an
alcoholic you really like alcohol
it's an end it's an anti-anxiety agent
of a potency
and it's a stimulant it's a great drug
and so once you have a great drug a
great spirit let's say you need
something better to replace it with
and maybe you can find something better
it appears that way because people do
and then they stop drinking
and so
and then there's service civic service
to your community you know i've been
thinking about church lately people have
abandoned the churches and vice versa in
many ways
and people think you know i can't
believe what the church teaches it's
like first of all who cares what you
believe like who are you anyways
right well really it's like i'm 16 i
don't like what the church teaches yeah
that's who you are you're the judge of
the church and you're 16. and that's
like that's commonplace i know it's
funny but it's not because that's a
common place that was certainly me at
16. who could believe that
you know i'm above that it's like really
here's this 15 year old juvenile
delinquent from northern alberta and
it's like
who cares about
saint augustine anyways you know what
did he know
so yeah so civic duty well i'm not going
to go into politics because it's a snake
pit you know or maybe you're cynical
about social institutions it's like well
go fix them
right you know they'll give you
something to do if they're so wrecked
great
well
[Applause]
it's an opportunity
you see something broken
fix it
and then you're the person who fixes it
like good for you man it's like you've
got something to do really and then
people think hey you're the guy that
fixed that maybe you could fix this
and this and this and this and then you
fix things and your life just expands
you know
i guess i'll tell you too something
about telling the truth so one thing i
did of 1985
82
83
82
i i swore that i would stop lying
i said i'm going to try not to say
anything i know to be untrue you know
that doesn't mean i swore to tell the
truth because truth that's hard but you
can consciously stop
lying when you know you're lying
you can stop doing that
and that has been revolutionary for me
and and one of the things i've really
realized in recent years and this is
very much worth knowing is that
many times when people speak to each
other
they have an agenda in mind you know
you want something from someone maybe
you want a job and you want to craft
your image
to get the job right so you say what you
need to say to get what you think you
need the problem with that is what do
you know about what you need you're so
accurate about that are you
and you think you know what you need
exactly and so you're gonna
falsify your utterances to bring about
the desired end and you're gonna use the
other person as a target of your
manipulation
well that's like you write an essay
because that's what the professor wants
to hear it's like you don't do that
because you don't falsify your words
because hypothetically they're divine
and the whole stability of the state
rests on them hypothetically and maybe
really too
and so you don't do that
and so instead you strive to tell the
truth and maybe that's a name too
and then it's an adventure because i'll
tell you one thing if you tell the truth
you have no idea what's going to happen
to you
because you have to let go of that it's
like i'm going to say what i think and
then what i'm going to assume faith i'm
going to assume that whatever happens if
i am telling the truth is the best thing
that could happen because the truth
brings about what is best and even if it
looks hard for me because it might be
you know because people take the easy
way out often when they lie even if it
looks bad for me
that doesn't mean it's bad it just means
i don't see the whole
i don't see the whole picture and you
know if you believe that the truth will
set you free and that there is such a
thing as the truth and that the truth is
redemptive then you're pretty much stuck
with that conclusion but one of the
remarkable things about that and this
really is worth knowing is that if you
do that you will have your adventure
right the that's the abrahamic adventure
you know the call from god that
justifies your life because of the
excitement of what you're doing and the
truth does that and then if it's the
truth man it's your adventure because
what bloody adventure are you having if
you tell someone else's story
it's not yours
and maybe if it's not yours it's not
good enough for you and then you suffer
and then you're better and then you're
cruel and then you're resentful
that's not good or you get arrogant
so
so you break up your life you know into
practicalities your career your
education
your intimate relationship your marriage
your friendship hopefully your intimate
relationship and your marriage are the
same thing
your use of time outside work your civic
duty you know and you develop an image
for yourself a vision for yourself on
all those fronts and assume that you can
have with the proper sacrifices what you
need and want and then i'll say
something interesting about that because
that's the pursuit of
goods in a practical way right in what's
valuable in a practical way in an
implementable way and you pick those
pathways and you dedicate yourself to
their optimization along any of those
axes and then you learn to optimize a
name
and then you see once you've learned to
optimize a name across a set of goods
you start to aim at what is what unites
those goods
because that's what makes goods good
it's whatever is common across a set of
goods that's the highest good or a
higher good and so by practicing any
good in any rigorous sense and making
the proper sacrifices in that direction
you simultaneously learn to approach the
good that is the sum or the essence of
all those
proximal goods and i would say that
the
the essential
insistence in christianity is that the
good that unites all those goods is the
same good that's reflected in the image
of christ which is an image of
acceptance of the suffering of life and
the necessity of serving the lowest as
the highest calling
and that's something and it might be
true
like really actually 100 percent true
more true than anything else and i
actually think it is partly because the
freest societies that we have that the
world has ever known the more successful
societies are predicated on precisely
that idea
as an unshakable foundation a
self-evident truth in the case of your
country and so it might be true and if
it is true and if that is real then why
in the world would you ever attempt to
do anything else
and it's kind of earth shattering in
some sense to take this with real
seriousness you know it's all very
frightening if you're not afraid by of
that of that vision you know and what it
implies for you
and your soul then you didn't understand
it but it's also an
unbelievably
what would you say endlessly promising
vision of what your life could be and
you know you might think well i need a
life so rich that i can justify its
suffering
and that's really asking for something
because there's no shortage of suffering
in life and it's no one thinks their own
suffering isn't real
and maybe there's a possibility that
there's some aim that's so high that
that the attempt
that the attempt alone to move in that
direction is of sufficient value to
act as a panacea for the suffering and
so you could say at the end of your life
oh my god that was so hard
it was worth it
and so that's the choice you make at the
crossroads
if you have any sense
oh
thank you
[Applause]
that was wonderful thank you
very much
the talent
upon the recommendation of the faculty
of hillsdale college and the authority
vested in me by its board of trustees
i confer upon jordan b peterson the
honorary degree doctor of humane letters
you know it's very difficult
so it's good
[Applause]
jessica
bill atherton was on our board of
trustees for it must be 40 years i think
it's even a little longer than that
he's from oklahoma city
he's uh went to oklahoma state he's from
tulsa
he's been in every kind of business the
oil business the food business
pepsi
taco hut
he's uh generous with the college and
generous with his time and counsel and
it's the time in council that makes an
impression
because you know when i came here
there were certain complications
and uh he was extremely helpful with
those
he's a wise man and a fine man
now he can't be here today
but he has sacrificed his daughter to us
she is now on the board of trustees of
the college
and
he wants her to carry on and she's up to
it and so to receive the honorary degree
doctor of public service
for bill atherton
jessica fober
[Applause]
and bill if you're watching i'll make
the obvious comment
thank god you married a pretty woman
senior class president is jacob hooper
get up here jacob
[Applause]
hey stay there
i think this is my 23rd time doing that
and i think i've got that wrong every
time
the hillsdale college chamber choir
[Applause]
is
[Music]
but the church
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
into the key
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what we have once
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
recipes
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
is
[Music]
[Applause]
now it's time hooper where are you
oh he's up here well he's prepared
unlike me
jacob is the senior class president
he's a history major
he's in all the great job by the way
choir
well done
jordan peterson is very impressed with
the music around here
so
they're going to have music now i can
see it at ralston college
we'll help them
uh jacob is a fine young man
good and easy to work with
his
teachers tell me some funny stories
about him
but they're not my story so i'm not
going to read them
he's in
the federal society and the catholic
society and mocked all the lawyer stuff
and of course he's an eagle-style scout
he's going to george mason university
law school
jacob hooper
[Applause]
thank you to all who join us today
dr arn
dr peterson the platform party faculty
and staff
family and friends
and of course
my class of 2022
but there's one more person in
particular that i would like to thank
dr patricia bart
could you please stand up
there she is
doctor no dr barr keep standing please
stand back up
my freshman year i took your great books
class
yes i did
and early on in the semester you had us
turn in an annotated bibliography for a
research paper that we wanted to write i
know you remember that
in fact you didn't give me the infamous
see that we all feared
you gave me a d-minus
you can imagine i was mortified by the
grade at the time
but through your hard work
and
you know actually a lot of guidance but
hard work on my end
so i flipped those
i was able to get a b plus
on the final research paper so in other
words your boy bounced back
thank you dr bart
you're
good at our freshman convocation dr
aaron told us a lot
but he specifically told us to get your
boots on
after i received that d-minus
i knew he was being serious
but that experience
reminded me of two rules that i used to
recite every week when i was a boy scout
in fact these rules are the final words
of the boy scout oath
mentally awake
and morally straight
now for us hillsdale students staying
mentally awake requires a little bit
more than just surviving a classroom
lecture
such as coming from dr gaetano
he got professor of the year so i can
make the joke
but staying mentally awake requires us
to continue learning outside of the
classroom and throughout our adult lives
just like with what dr peterson was
telling us
fact hillsdale alumnus paul ray who's
one of my role models
once gave me an excellent piece of
advice
he said to take a book every day
and had to have nothing to do with your
job
and just read it for 20 minutes
and by doing that
you'll learn something new
but in order to do that we have to have
this inherent desire to learn and to
expand our knowledge
is given that to us
and there are many examples on campus
how we already expanded our knowledge
take for example shane smith recently he
published an article in the nature
astronomy journal about how to use radio
technology to detect extraterrestrial
life
he put the fund back in physics
but our desire to expand our intellect
will also allow us to disseminate and
articulate ideas that will protect and
expand our religious and civil liberties
and many of us here today
will be hard at work doing that
some of us by staffing our hospitals
like matt granzado
going to seminary and leading our
congregations like john vascaro and
mason bailey
and teaching the next generation the
western heritage
like julia o'neil
continuing to learn and thereby staying
mentally awake is a fundamental step to
achieving self-government
now he also does has taught us a lot
about how to rise to self-government
but it takes a little bit more than just
book smarts it requires the practical
knowledge to solve everyday problems
that we will certainly face
the best example of this that i can
think of
is understanding the basic maintenance
of a car
back who's laughing at that that's not
funny
back when i was a sophomore i went to
super cuts which might be a surprise
because i am almost bald under this cap
but i i drive there in my car katie the
gmc acadia
and i love her dearly
she's seen a lot she has about 300 000
miles
now
after i got the hot towel treatment at
supercuts i uh went back to the car i
turned the key over and nothing happened
and i sat there
i don't know what to do i was an idiot
at that point
so i called my dad
and luckily my dad was able to drive
down from grand rapids and he was able
to bail me out
he took a screwdriver and a new mass
airflow sensor a park that that's about
this big
and he put it in the car that night in
the parking lot and i stood by and
watched him do it
i felt useless
i didn't know what to do i didn't even
know i did just a screwdriver for it
that experience taught me that i needed
to take responsibility for the
maintenance of my vehicle and at that
point self-government wasn't a theory
for me anymore
it was a dying katie
it's on us to learn how to solve
practical problems like diagnosing card
trouble and how to use the basic tools
that we need to fix them
taking those steps to learn how to solve
practical problems in addition to book
smarts
is staying mentally awake
and that will bring us closer to
self-government
but not all the way
we still need that second rule
to stay morally straight
and one of the best ways to do this is
to honor our parents
who have done so much to ensure we have
been successful
and that we are doing well
my own parents have done so much
to make sure that i got here today
they cooked my food
they helped me with my homework they
pushed my learning
they offer constructive feedback like
when they told me to stop lumbering
around at the back of laureate mass this
morning
they offered me this like guidance when
i was deciding between a couple colleges
and thankfully i ended here and not in
ann arbor
and my mom even accompanied me to courts
when i got a speeding ticket on a first
date
i won the case just to flex on you all
but
there was no second date
i'm sure many of you feel the same way
about your parents i know my younger
brother benjamin can say the same thing
my two aunts can say the same thing
about my grandparents
i certainly would not be able to stand
in front of you on this stage today if
it were not for my mom and dad
i will always be indebted to them
[Applause]
i told my mom she wasn't going to be
able to make it through my speech
without crying and i can see her back
there and her face is pretty red so
likewise with our parents we must tend
to the relationships we have formed
amongst our classmates really you people
here not over here you're too old
now i have a solid group of friends that
i've lived with for the last four years
we call ourselves the monastery
we call ourselves that name because
three of us are catholic and the fourth
one ben wilson is a work in progress
and when i first came to hillsdale i
thought i was the best catholic around
partly because of my little dutch town
of hudsonville there were no other
catholics
but upon meeting the other two catholic
members of the monastery david strobok
and brant siegfried
i saw that their faith eclipsed mine
brant teaches children at st anthony's
and he has hosted various small groups
during his time here on campus
this past year david strobak was the
president of catholic society he read
the prayer this morning at the
baccalaureate mass and he has been
instrumental to providing fundamental
ministry resources for the catholic
population on this campus
but not only did they know more about
their faith
they lived it out every day
their example
helped me strengthen my own faith
and help me understand it better
that impact
will follow me for the rest of my life
and then there's ben wilson
i can't make fun of him today because
his parents are allegedly sitting in the
front row i got to be careful because i
don't want his dad making funny faces at
me
but we have spent a lot of time together
we went to dc on whip
we pretended to be prospective students
at siena heights university last week
but through those little excursions
outside of hillsdale whether it was in
dc or a college visit
we learned to be grateful for all that
we have here
not only for our faculty care for us
but for our friends
who desire the best out of us
hillsdale has formed many tight-knit
friendships around here and they go well
past my little monastery crew
take for example carter woodland and
james vash elition
latter has three wise in his last name
and i said it right so whoever was
screaming over there like thank you i i
need that support
now they've lived in simpson for all
four years
and they got their friendship started
over pep band
if you go to the collegiate office
there's ring ganchieski and rachel
cookagee who've been able to bond over
their also tongue-twisting last names in
fact reagan's name is so difficult
she's using her mom's maiden name rhys
as her journalism byline
now we all have close friends and it's
critical
that we maintain the bonds that we have
formed on this campus
after all
we're social beings
but here at hillsdale
we are meant to be together as a family
and more importantly we are meant to
achieve self-government together
that
is staying morally straight
here at the college faculty like dr barr
and on the other side of the height
spectrum but just as intimidating
dr keltoff
they have done so much to ensure we have
received an excellent education
now if we
try to stay mentally awake and not work
before anyone on the politics apartment
gets on my case about that not woke but
if you stay mentally awake and morally
straight
not only will you expand your hillsdale
education
but you will come as close as humanly
possible to obtaining self-government
and along the way
you'll set down a path
and live an example for others to follow
for the same end
in other words
keep your boots on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
excellent job jacob
hoop i'm supposed to call him hoop
can't get used to that
well the candidates for doctoral degree
please stand and remain standing
well they can't
the candidates for master's degrees
please stand and remain standing
and will the senior class of 2022 please
stand
[Applause]
upon the recommendation of the faculty
of hillsdale college and with the
authority of its board of trustees
i confer upon each of you the degree for
which you have been a candidate and
admit you to all the rights privileges
and responsibilities to which you are
entitled and obliged
congratulations
[Applause]
so the doctor doctoral and master's
degrees in politics is first
and then after that the
master's degrees in government
and then we'll get to you
young ones
with the doctoral candidates from the
grand van endell school of political
philosophy statesmanship come forward
sarah jane aikey doctor of philosophy
politics
moritz peter muken
doctor of philosophy politics
casey j wheatland doctor of philosophy
politics
with the candidates for master's degrees
come forward
caleb boyer master of arts politics
jacob andrew bruns master of arts
politics
nicholas callahan master of arts
politics
paul andrew kluell master of arts
politics
lily ann duncan master of arts politics
nathaniel espin shade master of arts
politics
brian johnson freimoot master of arts
politics
caleb gabriel gabriel italy master of
arts politics
samuel lair master of arts politics
josiah lippencott master of arts
politics
[Music]
nathan nephew master of arts politics
christina marie slipkey master of arts
politics
christian warner master of arts politics
sarah weaver master of arts politics
with the candidates for the master's
degree from the van nandle school of
government come forward
caitlin
alcy burke master of arts government
stephen david shaffer master of arts
governments
bridget christina weisenberger master of
arts government
with the candidates for the bachelor's
degree in accounting please come forward
jeremiah jonah cisternas tears bachelor
of arts accounting magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors accounting
owen thomas williams bachelor of arts
accounting
abigail alloys burns bachelor of arts
accounting summa [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors accounting
carissa lee henderson bachelor of arts
accounting magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in accounting
alexi autumn day bachelor of arts
accounting departmental honors and
accounting
anaya jessica varamus bachelor of arts
accounting
[Music]
blake kirk hawkins bachelor of arts
accounting
[Music]
with the candidates for the degree in
american studies come forward
anna kate
josette reagan bachelor of arts american
studies
danae rebecca burdette bachelor of arts
american studies magna [ __ ] laude
would the candidates for the degree in
applied mathematics come forward
keith dooley bachelor of science applied
mathematics magna [ __ ] laude
[Music]
christiana lemoine bachelor of science
applied mathematics and biology summa
[ __ ] lauda departmental honors biology
benjamin aidan hufford bachelor of
science applied mathematics summa [ __ ]
laude
[Applause]
jean-luc p bell uncle bachelor of
science applied mathematics and
economics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in economics and mathematics
aaron james jacobson bachelor of science
applied mathematics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in mathematics
adam robert stacy bachelor of arts
applied mathematics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in mathematics
lilly christina van wingerden bachelor
of science applied mathematics [ __ ] laude
departmental honors mathematics
carl joseph weisenberger bachelor of
science applied mathematics summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in mathematics
[Applause]
would the candidates for the degree in
art come forward
madeleine ashton schneidsheider
bachelor of science art and biology
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
art and biology
elora joe gage bachelor of arts art [ __ ]
lauda departmental honors in art
grace helen cool
bachelor of science art [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors in art
ashton ruth mills bachelor of arts art
shannon christopher peterson bachelor of
arts art
[Applause]
reagan catherine lindy bachelor of arts
art and politics magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors art
with the candidates for the degree in
biochemistry come forward
alexander anschutz bachelor of science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
benjamin lawrence gendix bachelor of
science biochemistry departmental honors
biochemistry
bachelor of science biochemistry magna
[ __ ]
laude ray mcgarvey bachelor of science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors biochemistry
james michael mcclure bachelor of
science biochemistry
[Music]
morgan elizabeth cox bachelor of science
biochemistry [ __ ] lauda departmental
honors biochemistry
patricia lee becker bachelor of science
biochemistry [ __ ] lauda
matthew joseph granzado bachelor of
science biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
madison talley anderson bachelor of
science biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
sonia renee werkas bachelor of science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
congratulations jane francis desell
bachelor of science biochemistry summa
[ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biochemistry
[Music]
catherine rachel ingham bachelor of
science biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
claire francis mcnally bachelor of
science biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
molly janae buccola bachelor of science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors and biochemistry
rachel julianne gans bachelor of science
biochemistry
with the candidates for the degree in
biology come forward
claire cecilia froman bachelor of
science biology and exercise science [ __ ]
laude
emma brennan shay
bachelor of science biology magna [ __ ]
laude
melissa beth weaver bachelor of science
biology
kiara jean coselli bachelor of science
biology and psychology summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in both biology and
psychology
brian david hickey bachelor of science
biology magna [ __ ] laude
lucas william fetterson bachelor of
science biology and exercise science
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biology
corinne elizabeth wegner bachelor of
science biology
thank you
jared michael clark bachelor of science
biology magna [ __ ] laude
jack douglas shannon bachelor of science
biology
maxwell christian boyle bachelor of
science biology
jack miller reinhardt bachelor of
science biology summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biology
megan elizabeth phelps bachelor of
science biology [ __ ] laude
rose garrison koster bachelor of science
biology class valedictorian
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biology
sydney lynn crawford bachelor of science
biology
faith amber linton bachelor of science
biology magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biology
daniel sheamus
vote hole
bachelor of science biology
noah willard yoots bachelor of science
biology
with the candidates for the degree and
chemistry come forward
lauren carolyn benson bachelor of arts
chemistry magna [ __ ] laude
genevieve grace griffin bachelor of
science chemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in chemistry
kyla marie schnell
bachelor of science chemistry magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors and
chemistry adam berry ware bachelor of
science chemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in chemistry
cliff l yang bachelor of science
chemistry valedictorian summa [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors in chemistry
would the candidates for degree and
classics come forward
lindy grace leatherwood bachelor of arts
classics
[ __ ] laude
claire morgan wilkinson bachelor of arts
classics magna [ __ ] laude
and kathleen rolfe bachelor of arts
greek and latin
suma [ __ ] lauda departmental honors and
classics
elizabeth nancy hughes bachelor of arts
latin summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in classics
ambrose joseph bykirk
bachelor of arts in greek and latin [ __ ]
laude
hope
she won lad bachelor of arts greek and
latin summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in classics
would the candidates for the degree in
economics come forward
kevin michael sheesh
tucker stucker
bachelor of arts economics summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in economics
john vincent ortman bachelor of science
economics
jackson daniel kosnick bachelor of arts
economics
sarah ashley strauss bachelor of arts
economics
ava a hill bachelor of arts economics
bachelor of art of science economics and
mathematics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors economics
jack james shelley bachelor of arts
economics
joshua caleb antonini bachelor of arts
economics
conrad roland ludwig bachelor of science
applied mathematics and economics
departmental honors in economics
danielle marie baganski bachelor of arts
economics
mary kate brock's bachelor of science
applied mathematics and economics [ __ ]
lauda departmental honors in economics
benjamin luke beast bachelor of arts
applied mathematics and economics summa
[ __ ] laude
tavio alexanders pella bachelor of arts
economics and philosophy summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in economics
preston bruce baker bachelor of arts
economics
lucia may catcher bachelor of arts
economics and french magna [ __ ] laude
vera coutura james mcintosh bachelor of
arts economics
[Music]
jonathan david bauman bachelor of arts
economics and german magna [ __ ] laude
benjamin william bower bachelor of arts
economics and german magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in economics
[Music]
high trivia win
bachelor of science economics and
mathematics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and economics
thomas stephen rogers bachelor of arts
economics
thomas garen burscher
bachelor of arts economics magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in economics
drew carson godsell bachelor of arts
economics and german summa [ __ ] laude
department of honors in economics
andrew joseph walker bachelor of arts
economics magna [ __ ] laude department of
honors in economics
jillian alexandra jordan bachelor of
arts economics and politics
hannah noel fleming bachelor of arts
economics [ __ ] lauder
isabel jennifer machievsky bachelor of
arts economics
andrew christopher jovanetti bachelor of
arts economics
lauren hallie daffenberg bachelor of
science economics and mathematics summa
[ __ ] laude departmental honors in
economics
andrew james nell bachelor of arts
economics
anthony raymond lamacchia bachelor of
arts economics
michael sean edward craig bachelor of
science economics magna [ __ ] laude
department of honors and economics
sophia joe spanazzi bachelor of arts
economics and politics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in economics
congratulations
caroline gayle shelton bachelor of arts
economics
joseph michael bentley bachelor of arts
economics [ __ ] lauda departmental honors
in economics
joseph thaddeus hissam bachelor of arts
economics and history
candidates in english please come
forward
morgan alexis billingsley bachelor of
arts english magna [ __ ] laude
grayson may howard bachelor of arts
english
alexandra edna mary writer
bachelor of arts english
congrats
elizabeth grace johnson bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
claire catherine kearns bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
megan jane kepcke bachelor of arts
english
alison ann moss bachelor of arts english
and latin summa [ __ ] laude
isabella and hedrick bachelor of science
english
susannah christiana greene bachelor of
arts english
lydia joy parolin bachelor of arts
english [ __ ] laude from the class of
2020.
good job
matthew stuller mcgrory bachelor of
science english
daniel paul wrongly bachelor of arts
english
[Music]
seth dean ram bachelor of arts english
natalie kalia kent bachelor of arts
english [ __ ] laude
madeline olivia bray bachelor of arts
english
mari therese wellenmeier
bachelor of arts english [ __ ] laude
helen mariah murdock bachelor of arts
english summa [ __ ] laude
hannah marie breeding bachelor of arts
english [ __ ] laude
matisse richard bell uncle bachelor of
arts english and economics summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors economics
elena grace nabarowski bachelor of arts
english
is katya cliff bachelor of arts english
ashley christina warden bachelor of arts
english [ __ ]
laude elizabeth tone bachelor of science
english summa [ __ ] laude
shelby alexandra tone bachelor of
science english summa cumulator
shelby noel hufford bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
kathleen mary branigan bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in english
april elizabeth smith bachelor of arts
english and music [ __ ] laude
sophia judith maeda bachelor of arts
english [ __ ] laude
[Music]
victoria grace nunez bachelor of arts
english [ __ ] laude
grace noel bennett bachelor of arts
english
jamie marie burma bachelor of arts
english
what
greta lynn dornbeer bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
with the candidates in exercise science
come forward
taylor kate boyle bachelor of science
exercise science
okay
zalanya giselle claire eby bachelor of
science exercise science
alana marie o'leary bachelor of science
exercise science magna [ __ ] laude
[Music]
elizabeth kate overmon bachelor of arts
exercise science magna [ __ ] laude
jacob wells hamilton bachelor of arts
exercise science
brett james parks bachelor of science
exercise science
gabrielle alexander nichols bachelor of
science exercise science [ __ ] laude
austin christopher yarian bachelor of
science exercise science
financial management right
candidates in financial management come
forward
tavon anthony brown bachelor of arts
financial management
nathaniel david william chambers
bachelor of arts financial management
peter nybour bachelor of arts financial
management magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and financial management
calvin winthrop andrews bachelor of arts
financial management
francis calvin mcnelly bachelor of arts
financial management and politics [ __ ]
lauda departmental honors and financial
management
nolan james sullivan bachelor of arts
financial management [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors in financial
management
benjamin lewis raffin bachelor of arts
financial management
thank you
andrew rocco chefs bachelor of arts
financial management departmental honors
in financial management
nathan david bruhan bachelor of arts
financial management departmental honors
and financial management
tanner kayton motsky bachelor of arts
financial management departmental honors
in financial management
shane steger
senk
bachelor of arts financial management
departmental honors and financial
management
apollo johannes mettler bachelor of arts
financial management departmental honors
in financial management
david brady hunter bachelor of arts
financial management summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and financial
management
john luke hawk bachelor of arts
financial management [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors and financial
management
ian alexander kenrick bachelor of
science financial management [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors in financial
management
john thomas mccarthy bachelor of arts
financial management
matthew lewis harding bachelor of arts
financial management magna [ __ ] laude
alec thomas foose bachelor of arts
financial management [ __ ] laude
cole thomas johnson bachelor of arts
financial management summa [ __ ] laude
joseph richard royer bachelor of arts
financial management
kyle perrin bachelor of arts financial
management
would the candidates for the degree in
french come forward
mariana elizabeth cestaro bachelor of
arts french magna kuma lauda
departmental honors in french
peter john curtis bachelor of arts
french
with the candidates for the degree in
german come forward
joseph zacconi bachelor of arts german
and history
jacob levi likens bachelor of arts
english and german
alexander richard bukhite bachelor of
arts german and history summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in german
history
would candidates for the degree in
history come forward
here we go
brant christopher siegfried
bachelor of arts history magna [ __ ] laude
all right
jacob michael hooper bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
david jason strobock bachelor of arts
history and philosophy and religion
magda [ __ ] lauda
brennan thomas knockelby bachelor of
arts history and religion
ethan edward burer bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude
blake thomas newberry bachelor of
science applied mathematics and history
spencer lawrence woodford bachelor of
arts history
ryan scott perkins bachelor of arts
history
carter ross woodland bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude
joshua jerome moore bachelor of science
history
jacob carlisle crosley bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
john patrick joseph rowe bachelor of
arts history and politics summa [ __ ]
laude
michael mcclelland devery fleischer
bachelor of arts history magna [ __ ] laude
andrew david hicks bachelor of arts
history
john alexander biscarro bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
william augustine smith bachelor of arts
history
paul thomas kerrigan bachelor of arts
history
paul joseph tinkle bachelor of arts
history
[Music]
kai alexander panathir bachelor of arts
history
harvey william peters bachelor of arts
history summa [ __ ] laude
john wyatt burroughs bachelor of science
history and mathematics summa [ __ ] laude
antonus robert lauschus
bachelor of arts history summa [ __ ] laude
marissa lorraine fairbank bachelor of
science history and psychology magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in psychology
stephanie lynn sukup bachelor of arts
english and history summa [ __ ] laude
thanks for your hard work
eliana theresa kernodl bachelor of arts
history summa [ __ ] laude
[Music]
christine lyons talent bachelor of arts
history summa [ __ ] laude
lila sarah stillman bachelor of arts
history
[Music]
jane austen o'connor bachelor of arts
history summa [ __ ] lauda
[Music]
penny ann hypel bachelor of arts history
[ __ ] laude
lauren hill hearn bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude
congratulations
alia sage krippen bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] lauda
all right
emily marie bricky bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] lauda
[Music]
sarah marie johnson bachelor of arts
german and history summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in history
rebecca colleen felton bachelor of arts
history class salutatorian summa [ __ ]
laude
sean nicholas o'day bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
lauren evelyn malanson bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
sophia margaret berryhill bachelor of
science history magna [ __ ] laude
luke christopher mori bachelor of arts
history
juan camillo vargas hernandez bachelor
of arts history [ __ ] lauder
alexandra nicole steinhauscher
hauser
heisler three times the charm
bachelor of arts history
anna lane clark bachelor of arts history
summa [ __ ] laude
with the candidates in international
business come forward
benjamin ross garfinkel bachelor of arts
international business and foreign
language departmental honors in
international business and foreign
language
john connor pearson bachelor of arts
international business foreign language
[ __ ] laude
[Music]
international relations
would the candidates and international
relations come forward
jacob wayne umholtz bachelor of arts
international relations [ __ ] lauda
mary aloysius greco bachelor of arts
international relations [ __ ] laude
what
would the candidates for the degree in
marketing management come forward
zachary james herzog bachelor of arts
marketing management [ __ ] lauda
margaret jude depor bachelor of arts
marketing management [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors and marketing
management
josie ann miller bachelor of arts
marketing management
madeline marie clark bachelor of arts
marketing management
anna elizabeth lamonico bachelor of arts
marketing management summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in marketing
management
with the candidates for the degree in
mathematics come forward
alexander
to shady
to shadow and sadie
bachelor of science economics and
mathematics [ __ ] lauda departmental
honors in economics
joshua george davenport bachelor of
science mathematics magna [ __ ] laude
mark connor miller bachelor of science
mathematics
sydney janae mckeel bachelor of arts
mathematics and political economy summa
[ __ ] laude departmental honors and
political economy
abigail rhys price bachelor of science
mathematics
summa [ __ ] laude department of honors in
mathematics
stephanie jane walker bachelor of
science economics and mathematics
rebecca ann briskey bachelor of arts
mathematics
emma virginia mears bachelor of science
mathematics
with the candidates for the degree in
music come forward
anna margaret feaser bachelor of arts
music
ellen rebecca hancock bachelor of arts
french and music
would the candidates for the degree in
philosophy come forward
riley preston lindsay bachelor of arts
philosophy magna [ __ ] laude
[Music]
nicholas robert sheffield bachelor of
arts philosophy summa [ __ ] laude
[Music]
christopher sorensen moody bachelor of
arts philosophy magna [ __ ] laude
daniel sebastian ambul bachelor of arts
philosophy summa [ __ ] laude
leo thomas schleeter bachelor of arts
philosophy magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
aidan quinn cyrus bachelor of arts
philosophy [ __ ] lauda
[Music]
zachary robert pilipuke bachelor of arts
philosophy
ryan patrick burbidge bachelor of arts
philosophy [ __ ] laude
anna mary cannon bachelor of arts
philosophy magna [ __ ] laude
eva carlson hall bachelor of arts
philosophy magna [ __ ] laude
chandler david hart bachelor of arts
philosophy magna [ __ ] laude
michelle bianchi bachelor of arts
philosophy [ __ ] lauder
pnr
philosophy
with the candidates for the degree in
philosophy and religion come forward
isaac andrew kirschner bachelor of arts
philosophy and religion
stephen john sullivan bachelor of arts
philosophy and religion [ __ ] lauda and
birthday boy
[Music]
isaac jacob studebaker bachelor bachelor
of arts philosophy and religion
andrew
noel gerard weigand bachelor of arts
philosophy and religion [ __ ] laude
julia rose o'neill bachelor of arts
philosophy and religion magna [ __ ] laude
[Music]
would the candidates for the degree in
physics come forward
shane cortland smith bachelor of science
physics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in physics
bachelor of science applied mathematics
and physics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in physics
[Applause]
alexander j dulemba bachelor of science
applied mathematics and physics [ __ ]
laude
would the candidates for the degree and
political economy come forward
gotcha
catherine calendar swope
bachelor of arts political economy
stephen luke edelblue bachelor of arts
political economy
harrison
james bear bachelor of arts political
economy
nicholas francisco lolly bachelor of
arts political economy
okay
lily margaret mchale bachelor of arts
political economy magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and political
economy
jack owen coker bachelor of arts
political economy
bachelor of arts political economy [ __ ]
lauda
mason brian bailey bachelor of arts
political economy [ __ ] lauda
[Music]
sabrina amira marie guyer bachelor of
arts political economy
would the candidates for the degree in
politics come forward
john kirk lanning bachelor of arts
politics magna [ __ ] laude
chloe and kersey bachelor of arts
politics
joseph walter hoppy bachelor of science
economics and politics [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors in economics
bridget karen o'neill bachelor of arts
politics [ __ ] laude
shane patrick o'grady bachelor of
science politics [ __ ] laude
zachary fullerton nebolt
bachelor of arts politics and spanish
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors
politics and spanish
pretty good thank you
congratulations
michael steven lee bachelor of arts
politics
charles everett buffkin bachelor of arts
politics [ __ ] laude
camden scott schaefer bachelor of arts
politics
easy enough
benjamin davis wilson bachelor of arts
politics
grant winston boys bachelor of arts
politics magna [ __ ] laude
mitchell dean jesse bachelor of arts
politics
sean a hayduck bachelor of arts politics
francis
luis lucetti bachelor of arts politics
congratulations
mary grace gregg bachelor of arts
politics [ __ ] laude
samantha ann malcolm bachelor of arts
politics summa [ __ ] laude
carmelina a pestrido bachelor of arts
latin and politics summa [ __ ] laude
ruth moreno bachelor of arts politics
sumo [ __ ] lauda
kenna jane hayes bachelor of arts
politics summa [ __ ] laude
caroline jane welton bachelor of arts
politics
would the candidates in psychology come
forward
john stearns williams barstow
bachelor of science psychology
brandon michael corhonen bachelor of
arts philosophy and psychology
[Music]
sarah catherine malloy bachelor of arts
psychology [ __ ] lauda
peyton robert cole bachelor of science
psychology [ __ ] laude
jade summer juniper bachelor of arts
psychology [ __ ] lauda
gladys
janina
oster bachelor of science psychology
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
psychology
bachelor of science psychology magna [ __ ]
laude
leilani shang wang bachelor of science
psychology summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in psychology
sarah elizabeth hot bachelor of science
psychology summa [ __ ] laude
matthew gregory malcolm bachelor of
science psychology and religion
[Music]
patrick thomas cartier bachelor of
science psychology [ __ ] lauda
would the candidates for the degree in
religion come forward
ethan emmett hill richards bachelor of
arts religion
hannah lauren robinette bachelor of arts
religion
stephen michael whitney bachelor of arts
religion
paul jacob marcellus bachelor of arts
religion magna [ __ ] laude
elijah matthias quang bachelor of arts
religion [ __ ] laude
would the candidates in rhetoric and
public address come forward
rachel louise kukuji bachelor of arts
rhetoric and public address summa [ __ ]
laude
cassidy ray smith bachelor of science
psychology and rhetoric and public
address magna [ __ ] laude
madeleine diana schmidt bachelor of arts
rhetoric and public address magna [ __ ]
laude
catherine grace hall bachelor of arts
philosophy and rhetoric and public
address
james roman vasolition bachelor of arts
rhetoric and public address [ __ ] laude
adele brown bachelor of arts rhetoric
and public address
sociology
with the candidates in sociology and
social thought come forward
sophia grace pierce
bachelor of arts sociology and social
thought [ __ ] lauda departmental honors in
sociology
with the candidates for spanish come
forward
aislin rose sullivan bachelor of science
spanish summa [ __ ] laude
emily rose ogara bachelor of arts
spanish magna [ __ ] laude
grace elizabeth lucetti bachelor of arts
spanish
hannah ruth stinnett bachelor of arts
spanish [ __ ] lauda
jonathan taylor burton bachelor of arts
politics and spanish
would the candidates for the degree in
sports management come
forward joseph bradley schneider
bachelor of arts sports management
would the candidates for the degree in
theater come forward
sebastian james pistrido bachelor of
arts politics and theater [ __ ] lauda
departmental honors in theater
kirby b thigpen
bachelor of arts theater [ __ ] lauda
[Music]
andrew guerrero heimbach bachelor of
arts international business foreign
language and theater
is there anybody who thinks they deserve
or have earned a degree and forgot to
come up
seeing none on behalf of the hillsdale
college faculty i wish to send my
congratulations to all graduates
best wishes to you all godspeed in your
future endeavors and do
keep that partnership come back and see
us dr arne the awarding of degrees is
complete
thank you professor
and just
just when you think it's over another
guy in a robe gets up to talk i'm sorry
but i will be very brief i was going to
speak more extensively but dr jordan
peterson covered most of the topics i
had planned to talk about
actually i am here in my capacity my
proud capacity as chairman of the board
of trustees of hillsdale college and i'm
representing the board when i uh first
of all thank the graduates for all they
have brought to this campus over the
last several years to congratulate them
for uh completing this arduous journey
uh you have not only uh received a
world-class education you've learned
what it takes to be a a good and
effective citizen you've spent time
thinking about and mulling about and
talking about
the good and the true and the beautiful
all that is inside you now and it's just
up to you to get out there and and shine
a light on the world
from all of us here again
congratulations to the 170th graduating
class of hillsdale college
and uh we're going to ask you you've
been sitting a long time we're going to
ask you to stand now for the alma mater
the bed addiction and the processional
[Music]
[Music]
bringing distinction
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is here may we keep our dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
faith in life becomes
[Music]
white and blue
man please remove your caps
by the grace of almighty god may you be
filled with the knowledge of his will
and all wisdom and understanding
so as to walk in a manner worthy of the
lord who calls you
fully pleasing to him and bearing fruit
in every good work
and may you be strengthened in the inner
man with all power
according to his glorious might for all
endurance and patience giving joyful
thanks to him in all things
and the blessing of god almighty father
son and holy spirit be amongst you and
remain with you all forever
amen
upon
he shall give
you peace
[Music]
us
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so
bye